this almost sent you for a bit of a spin
just because it's like man what does
that wouldn't any of that even mean
right okay you've got two complex
numbers that's the easy part we want to
find a number and positive it to jump
right so that's what pouty ona raises to
such that when you take the cushion on
these two and then you raise that power
you end up with a completely real number
okay now let's just stop for a second
and simplify this a little bit don't
worry about the fact that it's a um it's
a question okay just think about if I
took this number here
hi on three high-priority okay in order
for a complex number to be completely
real right a complex number to be
completely real what does that look like
let me draw my own complex plane again
what I mean is that the number after
some times of multiplication right I end
up back over here or over here right
either the positive real axis or the
negative real axis okay now let's just
make it a percent here if all I care
about is the number being real right
how important is the modulus to them and
the answer is it's not that important at
all right because if I'm here or here or
here or here I'm still going to be real
right side I'm not that interesting the
modules so therefore this question is
really a question about the argument so
I think a question about hanging now
what kind of angle am i interested in
let's think about this number this is
very easy to plot okay if I said all
right - lets just make this X - okay
pilot three where's pilot three on my
dining room three how many degrees is
partly right it's about one thing it's a
bad CT what about it's exactly 60
degrees okay so therefore I'm thinking
I'm gonna be about yeah
ish I'm gonna call that Zen one okay now
every time I multiply for a moment I'm
going to forget about than one dose of
Americus again I'm only interested
whether
which taxes is I don't are just
interested me are you if I multiply this
tub at once here and if I square it
where will I go I double the angle go
right okay so 60 will become 120 okay
now keep in mind like this numbers
actually to be further away why is it
gonna be further away because you just
rotate do you think to scale and you
stand right so I'm getting further away
but the thing I'm really interested is
the angle okay so he might be z1 squared
when would said one cubes big the angle
the angle will be tripled from the
original right so thinking back in
degrees 60 degrees to become 180 right
or more accurately pilot 3 will become
but okay so I'm gonna come down to here
so now will the real axis are you happy
with that so if all my hand was just
said 1 and I said what power do I raise
you to such that you end up with a hole
in real love but the answer would be 3
do you agree with that like after the
third time I get back on to the real
axis so that number is holy really okay
so now what I'm asking is something just
a little more just a little more
complicated
that's all in terms of the arithmetic
Amin right how am I going to state this
for a number for this right to be holy
real I just want to say something about
its argument right so the argument oh
it's going to be now what can I say
about this thing what can I say about
this thing well all the positive real
axis my angles are like zero or what
other kinds of angles could I have 2 pi
4 PI 6 pi 8 pi they're all on the
positive real axis right what about
another negative real axis I'm a PI then
up
the replay and then 5 PI so I've got all
the odd multiples over here
now I haven't specified whether a
positive real number or a negative 1
it's just either of those ok
so therefore it's just some multiple of
Pi right just any whole number multiple
of Pi so I'm going to write writing like
this ok I'm not using n because I would
usually use n but there's already been
used up okay so does that make sense
this is what I'm after
ok so now if this is what I'm trying to
prove right this is one approach for you
now I guess that's a compute now I'm
ready to compute ok so let's say this
what is the argument what is the
argument of gists before we raise the
power what's the argument of the just
the first time we drew the question
right
well the question means subtraction of
angles right because multiplication
means the addition of English so this is
going to be our said 1 now I'm dividing
right of dividing so I'm going to
subtract the other items it you okay
with that so I've got the first time
really a PI on 3 I'm subtracting what
argument negative point 4 I'm just
reading it off so what's this ok so
that's just what happens when I do it
was but according to de Mars they're
right for you to do if I raise it to
some bigger payoff Z was on z2 and raise
that thing to the end ok then the
argument of this new number is I'm gonna
add this argument on repeatedly how many
times am I going to Adam enter in times
right so
to say this is seven and the PI on 12
and the reason I know that is because if
tomorrow's there yep very much because
why there why it's the number of times
I've gone around since the number of
angles I've added okay so now the
question remember is Phi the smallest
positive integer for n that's gonna make
that a whole number do you see that
right i won
I want seven and on 12 to be a whole
number
okay now seven to 12 are what we call on
or seven to prime number okay so it's
not gonna share anything you're 12
except for one which is not very useful
okay so therefore what number do I have
to multiply 7 by such a it'll go into 12
the answer is 12 okay
so therefore when N equals 12 right
what will the argument be 2 to the 12
and I'm gonna pop the brackets around
there because I'm not raising the
argument to the 12th power I'm raising
the complex number to the 12th power
which gives me 7 times 12 pi on 12 okay
so you can see that's gonna give me 7 pi
and that's and you can see as well if I
subtract any multiple of 7 pi dunno the
previous ones will be whole numbers okay
they're always going to be awkward
fractions because 7 isn't good ok so
therefore that's my entire n equals 12
that's the first number that makes this
quotient raised to a power completely
real okay before we leave off what if I
wanted to be completely imaginary
so for instance if we come back to this
guy right Payan 3 2 pi on three three
player thing which is pi and that's what
I get to real how many times do I have
to go around to get to the imaginary
axis for this number this number over
here is just piled three let me just
rehearse this for you so you can see the
answer all right
there's it once this one's about square
visit one cubed then 1 to the 4 is going
to be yeah right Zed 1 to the 5 week
here where's it once on the 6 go to be
said 1 to the 6 what happens to the
angle if I'm raised to the sixth power
according to de moivre's theorem I'm
going to multiply the angle by 6 which
will be 2 pi I'm back to here hold on
that's a problem isn't that problem I'm
never going to get to imaginary axis on
this stuff for anyway
do you see I'm on real complex complex
real complex complex but I'm never gonna
know multiple I'm just going to keep
back on on this one right on that
argument okay so this time at a many how
many times you multiply it but will
never get you to the completely
imaginary axis what argument we said
hold on the multiples of pi will be real
what are the arguments of the positive
imaginary axis and the negative
recommences i'll to give me another
angle I've got to go to get back here
I'm gonna go to PI around right that'll
give me 5 pile - that's okay right
give me another one that's okay how
about this guy down here
- power - or can you give me a positive
1/3 times 3 PI - we'll do it right or
five five seven seven five sorry added
for 75 or - etc okay so what can you now
say about these multiples of Pi they're
not whole number multiples either they
have to be odd that more than odd though
don't they
now do you odd and they have to be
divided by they're all on - I they have
to be to get up onto the right angle
okay so in other words the way I'd say
it is instead of saying this I would say
okay now this easy part it's all one -
how do I have an odd number I will make
an odd number two K PI would be even
numbers Fred - K PI because that would
give you 0 to 4 if I want LOD numbers
right I want author even numbers but off
by one right so I could do it either
- k plus 1 PI's or I could do - K - that
would still give me the odd numbers okay
you can see this is rather more
complicated which is why it's not the
first example I showed you okay but it
will come up just as much in fact you
can go ahead you can try this question
by this smallest positive integer such
that you don't get a wholly real number
but you get a holding a purely imaginary
you know but it's a bit trickier it was
very possible